now on good day waking up after tragedy
this morning we're learning more about
the eight people stabbed on the Strip
including two locals who lost their
lives and we are learning more about the
suspect accused of going on that
stabbing Rampage those details ahead and
what's next for Las Vegas resident
performer Donnie Osmond find out
retirement mmm I don't know but you're
also going to get a chance to win some
tickets to go see his show coming up in
a few minutes good day Las Vegas starts
right now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now 6 30 is the time here on this
Friday morning you know certainly lots
to get to obviously we're going to be
covering the situation that occurred on
the strip and and really just trying to
navigate and get through that here as a
community exactly and I'm a pat on the
back to everybody here at 8 news now and
to you guys for hanging in there as this
uh we didn't know what was going on it
all just happened so quickly and we do
our best to get the information to you
safely so you know that you're safe um
and word gets out fast I was I was
getting text messages from friends out
of state yesterday what is going on on
the Las Vegas Strip so uh it is we
certainly don't want people to be afraid
to come visit our beautiful city in our
fun town so uh but yes so we're getting
getting back to normal today and all of
our lives and a busy weekend it is a
busy weekend and then and of course hot
chocolate talking about one of the
things going on and a lot of people will
Sherry be outside yeah it's first Friday
downtown is it's Pride weekend and we've
got pride parade downtown and we've got
the the ren fair and there's just so
much again all all of that outdoors and
it is going to be a warm weekend so I
want you to be prepared got to get
hydrated if you're going to be spending
a lot of time Outdoors especially in the
warmth of the Day 70 degrees right now
we're cooling off from yesterday's 91.
days have been very similar haven't they
but they've been easy easy weather 30
percent humidity 37 is the dew point not
much in the way of wind and the sunrise
is just about about 10 minutes away it
takes a couple of extra minutes to come
up over the mountain 641 officially is
the sunrise so kiddos again I've been I
know I harp a lot on making sure you got
water in the backpack but it is
important and hopefully you're hitting
the water fountain at school and when
you head home those warm low 90s will
feel even warmer in the direct sunlight
so just have a great last day of school
this week and you're on to a wonderful
weekend we'll check that forecast coming
up 6 34 let's check the drive and you're
on to a pretty good commute when we're
talking about after 6 30 on a Finally
Friday the freeway is in pretty decent
shape obviously you got a lot of company
on the south 15 and it's even better
when you realize there's actually been a
couple of crashes here on the 15 in both
directions around Sahara but the good
news they're off on the shoulder so
these are the folks who are southbound
kind of between the spaghetti bowl and
down towards Sahara here they are out of
the roadway for you so that is good news
and even better news from the strip at
Spring Mountain of course shut down for
hours with the ongoing investigation
from yesterday you have obviously you
know that they shut down the exits from
Spring Mountain again that's all back
open we have a live picture even the
ongoing road work has been suspended for
the overnight hours you're back to full
Lanes on Spring Mountain and Las Vegas
Boulevard Heather
this morning we know the identity of the
man accused in that deadly stabbing
spree on the Strip Metro Police say this
man 32-year-old Johnny Barrio stabbed
and killed two people both from Las
Vegas and also hurt six others our
Candace Charles standing by to tell us
more about what we've learned about the
suspect first so let's get to what we
already know about this seemingly
unprovoked attack two killed six injured
just before noon in front of the win
according to the corner the victim's
both from Las Vegas have been identified
as 47-year-old Brent Hallett and 30 year
old maristegiovanni they were both
killed as for the other victims two were
recovering at Sunrise Hospital and are
expected to survive the others at UMC
one of them still listed in critical
condition this morning
now the man you see behind me that's
Yanni Barrios he's accused of this
violent deadly crime Candice Charles
joining us live this morning from this
trip to talk more about the suspect but
Candace really to tell us also what
you're seeing out there we know there's
a lot more police kind of actively
watching and making feel people feel
safe
yeah really in the light of day after
this horrific incident it's almost like
it didn't happen people are out here
running getting back to their normal
everyday situation and that's what
really is scary about being out here on
the strip and having something like this
happen people come out here to enjoy and
really feel comfortable on this trip but
to have something like this horrible
happen is it's quite horrific and of
course the police are still here on the
scene not only do we see police cruisers
we also see officers standing by many of
these escalators as well as extra
security inside of the casinos really
just to make sure people feel like
they're safe and that they're able to
come back to the strip now of course
this all happened after police say 32
year old Yani Berrios started stabbing
people right in front of the win here
eight people were stabbed two of those
people unfortunately died those folks
were actually from right here in Las
Vegas and take a look at this Advanced
video here of the suspect running from
the scene again after that man burial
stabbed eight people outside of the wind
police say burials used a large knife to
stop the victims again both of those
victims that did pass away are from Las
Vegas many of those folks are still in
the hospital we're still trying to learn
a little bit about their condition as
instant as you can imagine has everyone
on alert
this guy came ran up and started
stabbing this lady in front of me and
she ran around the escalators and then
she collapsed up under the bridge and
her girlfriend was trying to help her
and then and nobody was helping him just
ever except for her girlfriend
and then she stopped moving I mean we're
just going to be extra careful we're
careful we have our brother and our
husband with us and just you know stay
together
I guess that's a shocking situation
happen here on the Strip now burials is
being held in jail and is facing
multiple charges this morning he's
scheduled to appear in court later on
today of course we will have coverage so
stick with us right here on airline on
social for the latest and it is Friday
you guys there's a lot going on this
weekend so please stay safe and stay
alert as you can see and as I've said
police are out here so that is something
that is comforting for you guys this
Friday morning but for now live from the
Las Vegas Strip I'm Candace Charles 8
news now and Candace thank you just
reiterating that it is safe to be on the
Strip we're working on discovering a
motive there for the suspect thank you
in response to the stabbings the city of
Las Vegas increased the number of City
Marshals patrolling the Fremont Street
Experience City says they made this
decision out of an abundance of caution
Fremont certainly though has seen its
share of violence this year A man was
shot and killed in June prompting City
officials to look at a curfew along the
Fremont Street Experience and though
this most recent act of violence on our
Las Vegas strip was an isolated incident
violence on this trip has been a growing
concern in fact there was an arrest made
after a stabbing just last month outside
Caesar's Palace in that case though the
injuries were non-life-threatening in
August a man shot and killed a family
member at the Mirage hotel inside of a
room there two women were also injured
in that shooting and before that two
security guards were shot after a
shoplifting attempt this happened at the
world's largest gift shop that's on
Sahara and Las Vegas Boulevard it
happened in June in March a Taurus was
stabbed to death on the pedestrian
bridge between New York New York and MGM
Grand and this prompted County
Commissioners to redefine that bridge as
a crosswalk in order to prevent
loitering counties also working on a
proposal to keep anyone convicted of a
crime on the Strip out of the strip
corridor
you can find this full story and all of
the updates as we continue digging and
pressing for information
we're going to have it on our website
8newsnow.com and on our app which you
can download both in Google Play and in
the App Store
6 39 is the time and still to come here
on good day don't go anywhere we are
giving away tickets to see Donny Osmond
of course you know he's been around for
decades but is he done coming up he
reveals what's next in an interview
you'll see only here on channel 8. and
we're looking ahead to Monday already
Las Vegas Raiders taking on the Chiefs
in Kansas City and you don't have to go
anywhere because you can watch it right
here Channel 8 Monday night five o'clock
eight news now home of the most Raiders
games to Sherry well the Raiders are not
done please say Donny's not done please
all right we got a beautiful morning out
there that sun is just getting ready to
make it up over the eastern mountains
we've got gorgeous clear skies we're
down to 70 degrees right now we'll be
back into the mid to Upper 70s
mid-morning mid 80's by noon and another
extra warm day in the low 90s with upper
80s through your evening hours are there
any change is in this warm October
weather I've got the answer in your most
accurate weather now forecast and Nate
of course is watching the drive it's all
8 News Now
he's a singer actor host
Las Vegas Legend Donny Osmond currently
performing a sellout show at Harrah's
and he probably also saw him as the
peacock on The Masked Singer and the
list goes on and on
so what's next for the iconic performer
here's what he told me
you've done everything acting hosting
multiple shows the variety show pyramid
Etc what have you not done
what have I not done probably nothing
but that doesn't mean he's ready to slow
down I don't want to retire
it sounds boring to me he sold more than
a million albums worldwide and earned 33
Gold Records
I'm working on the 66th album right now
which I think will blow you away You're
gonna hit that goal I'm going to hit the
goal
and the concept that I'm working on
right now no one has ever done not only
is he working on a new album but going
for a record that's my goal is to hold
the record of
the most amount of Studio albums but but
it's not all about the music to him Show
Business means Evolution you got to keep
your mind open to a lot of things I
didn't know the mass singer was out
there I didn't know that the Dancing
with the Stars let alone winning it was
going to be there that's the cool thing
about Show Business you never know
what's going to happen and particularly
nowadays versus back in the olden days
when I started you have to be ready to
turn on a dime do you think you'll do
another autobiography to update I mean
it's been 15 years you know I've been
asked that uh I think it's inevitable I
don't know yet
because the story hasn't been finished
yet I'm still creating it
it is evolving and we love watching it
all right listen up Donny Osmond fans
this is your last chance to call in and
win caller number eight right now you
win four tickets and a VIP experience to
see Donny Osmond at Harrah's as well as
a 250 dollar dining credit at Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse inside Hera's that
number
702-650-1101 caller eight takes it home
good luck oh what a great giveaway what
a great prize
you can't retire Donnie you can't all
right